yes day one Oh Micah uh I'll just pick
two skeletons and shivers down your
spine pick the best character he's
totally overly from liver day yeah I
told you it's a weird looking and all
the buttons are the same as well hey I
got a bone to pick with you buddy good
one buddy
okay we're supposed to talk to the
farmer yeah new friend hey welcome to my
farm you gotta kill all those creatures
out there I know it seems cruel Oh God
wait they're not doing anything jack
what the [ __ ] are you doing stop they're
not neither innocent Jesus correct it's
the lion
or think new weapon in the barn
yeah point fine no Mike hey ed what
ak-47 time baby oh oh those creatures
are creeping over
oh my God look at that over there yes
it's really grinder oh my god we make
sausages if you didn't notice how guys a
couple water pumps out there on the farm
yeah yeah you can drink from them to
heal yourself come on drink it why is
this game good it's so shame and what's
it what's the point of the meat grinder
if you hit them they slide like oh my
god do now you know pigs are really
intelligent boy piggy this is exactly
what people think YouTube commentary is
all right all right there are other
things you need to learn that one's
pretty important it's the power light
hey Jack catch you have such a beautiful
smile
you take a [ __ ] all over your skull yeah
well so do you [ __ ] we got a revolver
now I guess you deserve this explosive
ammo and all the weapons today you hold
the revolver like Jesus really come on
go I got myself a piggy Sarge
yeah nothing bacon is where it's a hey
what happened you went inside give it on
top of it
young hell oh my God he's on that here
we go meat winding back some items oh we
need 104 what we need more what are you
doing I'm trying to get it in mmm
here we go then you look at the grinder
down here and we're almost to 100 and
400 nice noise oh shoot Nate and shoot
the puppy
I got a grenade ah mine I got a grenade
he's over there
amazed that was I'm gonna talk to
farmers Road farmer Dave sup Dave I
don't want to scare you but I think
things are gonna get a little bit more
tough on you I'm scared
the physics are so caulis chickens maybe
they are get out there come on fun don't
let me hold you back no no I'm just
gonna sleep this one out he's not moving
I'm dying I'm dying greedy Pig dying
just hi bug that ball I'm talking about
myself do you shoot
such a big oh my god Jack now
okay I'm really slow be careful
help you go your bony [ __ ] they're just
a theme tune again no clearly I'm not
fine and keep shooting
please I need to find a well [ __ ] save
just shoot at finder well it's right
here [ __ ] you [ __ ] you I'm getting the
well now you need my help
you need me yes
you sit down uh hey buddy how you doing
there net I'm almost dead need a hand I
need two bony hands please
there you go about it haha look at his
legs it was a fun adventure now I can
get myself out of here I'm gonna come
with me buddy just your journey Oh
it may gust attack decapitate it try
that again
Oh slow Jesus [ __ ] Christ his head we
gotta get you to school boy there it is